Щиро вітаємо вас у нашій студії Ми раді
що ви дивитесь нашу програму У фокусі
Європа на дворі осінь але в Європі вона
на диво тепла тому відчувається якось
незвично жовтень тут у Німеччині був
найтеплішим від початку метеоспорежень
через рекордні температури Все частіше
горять цілі регіони більшість людей
хочуть зупинити глобальне потепління Але
для того щоб скоротити викиди слід
відмовитись від видобутку вугілля газу
та нафти зараз світ обговорюється на
кліматичному саміті в Єгипті
потім кожна країна повинна діяти таку же
самостійно наприклад Швеція адже навіть
ціна батьківщині грете тумбер із
захистом клімату не все гладко і саме це
зараз помітно на крайній півночі Там
біля моніо над полярним колом у великих
масштабах вирубують ліси Це катастрофа
не тільки для клімату але й для оленярів
яким бракує лісу щоб прогодувати тварин
тому що там все повільно змінюється
варто завдячувати захисникам клімату
таким як Анна Лена лохаус яка кидає
виклик Могутньому лобі торговців лісу
так багато дерев немає жодна країна
Європи вони покривають три чверті
території на перший погляд Швеція
виглядає як суцільний ліс
але чим далі на північ Тим більше у
ньому прогалин і ліс перетворюється наче
на декорації
у багатьох місцях ландшафт виглядає наче
ви на Місяці якось тут уоніо на кордоні
між швецією та фінляндією 200 км над
полярним колом винні у цьому шведські
лісопромислові компанії
на табличках які грінки прикріпив на
деревах сказано не рубати
при суцільний вирубці викорчовують і
вивозять справді все
через 30-40 років рідшають висаджені
ліси
ці люди працюють Проти природи а не з
нею
один Лісник на своєму лісу
заготівельному комбайні Harvester знищує
стільки лісу як раніше могли лише два
десятки лісорубів
машини з великими шинами залишають
широкі смуги втоптаної землі тож не
дивно що тут багато років нічого не
росте
Тут також мали вирубити величезні площі
ліси належать шведському державному
лісопромисловому концерну связько
однак фірма не взяла до уваги екологів
із Green підстав оленярів Вони поставили
дерева під свій захист патрулювали їх і
місяцями виходили на демонстрації німий
протест
який змусив центральний офіс фірму у
цьому величезному будівельному комплексі
у центрі Стокгольма поступитися
стара верхівка змушена була піти Ми
зустрічаємо нового керівника
підприємства Еріка брансму у нашому
інтерв'ю він проявляє розуміння
раніше ми ставилися до цього конфлікту
не оптимально
ми не враховували інтереси оленярів не
дивилися на те як їм далі займатися
своєю професією
назад у ліси які належать концерну
зв'язку в районі моніо живе 4000
північних оленів влітку їжі для них Тут
достатньо восени напівдики тварини охоче
їдять гриби
Ми зустрічаємося із головою місцевого
оленячого кооперативу ганцом голмою
чи довіряє він новим обіцянкам
лісозаготівельного концерну
наразі кажу він ліс більше не вирубують
він сподівається що так буде й надалі
давно вже час
Звісно що ми сподіваємося на покращення
на новий курс
Ерік Братц був тут у нас на півночі
Але чесно кажучи це треба було зробити
ще 30 років тому
більшість старих лісів просто зникли
корм бракує передусім через те що клімат
божеволіє і відлиги та арктичні холоди
чергуються
лише тут у цьому рідкому лісі росте
зимовий корм легкі лишайники залишаються
на снігу і допомагають оленям
перезимувати
вирубувати так багато ми більше не
можемо особливо якщо ми хочемо знову
мати лишайники на деревах якщо хочемо
створити проходи для оленів та їх
захистити тож Звісно це впливає на наш
спосіб введення бізнесу
поки що у лісі табличок мир
надписи не рубати знімають
тепер дерева залишаються без захисту
тепер слідкувати повинен сам связко
наразі наші колеги з Грін пішла у
будь-якому разі довіряють і настільки що
вони пішли і тепер можуть присвятити
себе іншим справам
це хороший знак
екологи проти лісозаготівельного
концерну зазвичай дуже серйозні
противники
зрештою зв'язку вирішили У наступні роки
вирубувати на 20% менше можливо це
початок співпраці
2015 рік сотні тисяч сирійців тікають
від війни так званих балканським шляхом
до ЄС передусім до Німеччини однак
паркани на кордонах з Європою сьогодні
вище а контроль суворіший але зараз
знову тікають тисячі сирійців зокрема
мохамед він уже кілька років живе в
Туреччині але більше залишатися тут не
може каже він йому загрожує депортація
він уже подолав сотні кілометрів від
Туреччини до Греції і хоче рухатись далі
на північ Утім його шлях небезпечний
Мухамед і сирійського але похотів швидко
покинути Туреччину
ми зустріли 21-річного чоловіка поблизу
грецького кордону і з Північною
Македонією після майже 20 спроб втечі
каже він йому вдалося потрапити до
Греції
втеча небезпечно Але ще небезпечніше
було б якби Туреччина відправила мене
назад до табору біженців у Сирії
там я помер би від холоду дощу та снігу
студент живе у лісі разом із двома
десятками інших сирійців тут вони
почуваються у безпеці від поліції
Цей юнак показує свою шрами він каже
його побили грецькі поліцейські
попри насильству та небезпеку сирійці
знову наважуються втікати до Західної
Європи
після того як уряд ердоган почав
депортувати людей до Сирії більшість із
них більше не почуваються в Туреччині у
безпеці
і смертельно ризикують
у холодильній камері інституту судової
медицини в Олександру полі
судмедексперт Павло з павлідіс більше не
може приймати мертвих їх занадто багато
один труби з імені
тому він має лише номер
цими тижнями до павлідіса привозять
багато безіменних померлих їх знаходять
на прикордонній річці еврос
це все були люди які марно намагалися
потрапити до Греції з Туреччини до
Європейського Союзу
Я працюю у цьому інституті вже 20 років
але так погано цього року ще ніколи не
було у попередні роки у нас завжди було
близько 50 мертвих зараз 60 за перші 9
місяців
смертельно небезпека на прикордонній
річці еврос зросла після Великого
напливу біженців у 2015 році Греція
підвищила контроль і встановила високий
паркан на деяких ділянках
200-кілометрового кордону
крім того є повідомлення що в багатьох
мігрантів і біженців прикордонники
просто повертають назад Афіни
заперечують такі повернення
і звинувачують Туреччину всередині
жовтня на грецькому березі підібрали 92
особи переважно сирійських молодих людей
як вони пізніше розповідають їх гнали
роздягнутими на протилежних берег
турецькі прикордонники
Мухаммед щасливий що благополучно
добрався до Греції завтра він хоче
перетнути кордон із Північною Македонією
а звідти піти далі так званим
балканським маршрутом
Я хочу до Німеччини Я хочу вивчити там
німецьку отримати диплом інженера та
одружитися
мохамед і його друзі це не поодинокі
випадки
прикордонна поліція Греції спостерігає
збільшення нелегальних перетинів кордону
хоча й невеликими групами
оскільки нелегальний перетин кордону на
річці евро став складнішим багато хто
Готовий їхати в Об'їзд через Болгарію
тобто через гори
змінили свою тактику також і
контрабандисти
зараз у невеликих автомобілях або навіть
на мотоциклах везуть лише одну або дві
людини
завжди нові маршрути та ризики
судмедексперт павлідіс може підтвердити
Це зі свого щоденного досвіду
більше жертв потонули в річці або
померли від переохолодження також до
мене все частіше привозять жертву ДТП
Коли автомобіль для контрабанди людей
потрапляє в серйозну аварію то зазвичай
на жаль є більшою жертвою
намагається ідентифікувати жертви на
підставі прикрас та зразків ДНК
родичі у вічі щодня телефонують на його
мобільний телефон
для мене це такі ж самі Людські долі як
і всі інші
Мене не цікавить звідки вони прийшли у
що вірили які в них були політичні
погляди вони заслуговують на нашу повагу
і тому я намагаюся зробити все можливе
щоб їх ідентифікувати та передати їхні
тіла родичам
однак павлідність підозрює що поки що
люди все одно продовжуватимуть Помирати
на цій ділянці європейського кордону
страх за власне життя щодня присутній
також в Україні такі моменти важливими
стають маленькі речі які забезпечують
принаймні трохи нормальності
приміром яскраво нафарбовані нігті
оскільки навіть тоді коли навколо
падають ракети хочеться на мить почувати
сінакше війна війною а жінки залишаються
жінками твердо впевнена Українка Іра
Вона не хоче позбавляти себе можливості
мати гарний вигляд причепуритися трохи
відволіктися адже війна все ще триває
у Києві казка Ірі більше не потрібна але
на фронті на Донбасі це важливо А вона
саме звідти там вони з Анною носили
військовий одяг нарешті вони повернулись
до Києва Можливо вдасться навіть коротко
передихнути ще спочатку війни вони як
волонтерки перевозили автомобілем на
фронт усе що було необхідне мирним
мешканцям та військовим тепловізори
медикаменти бронежилети підтримуючи
солдатів на фронті обоє дуже часто
ризикують
Ми поверталися з бахмуту перед нами йшла
колона військова і вони Потрапили під
мінометний обстріл ми були буквально Ну
за десь за 150 метрів від вибухів під
час нашої поїздки Ми жваво розмовляємо
тема війни змінюється через секунду
темою косметики звучить смішно але в цій
ситуації Я Звертаю увагу на їхній нігті
Я з самого початку
що я маю бути красивою бо я не знаю коли
в мене буде ракету що я маю лишатися
красивою жінкою бажаною ми це
обов'язково
Для мене це важливо завжди було я дуже
багато проводжу часу за кермом дуже
багато і я вся змінилася Я за цей період
всі нормальні люди в війну худнують Я
набрала вагу я обстригла волосся Я
повертаюся коли з Донбасу я Ну просто
мегазмучена я дуже-дуже погано виглядає
але ну все одно як жінка мені хочеться
ну принаймні виглядати так як до війни
Коли ти бачиш такі нігті як у мене Ти
думаєш що вони брудні
він нормально
для мене якісь такі речі які то що є
довоєнне то що ти можеш перенести хоч
якусь там маленьку частиночку того що
було до війни і відчувати себе Ну дійсно
більш-менш нормально Ця війна настільки
масштабна Що складається враження що
дуже дрібні та звичні речі особливо
важливі як наприклад нігті до війни Іра
була асистенткою кінорежисера поки що
вона їздить як волонтерка туди-сюди між
фронтом і Києвом
через кілька днів Ми зустрічаємо її в
зовсім іншому світі у манікюрному салоні
дівчата ми зустрічаємося з якими іноді
там не бачимося ти можеш перетнутися з
кимось на манікюрі спитати як в неї
справи І поспілкуватися з майстром якесь
відволікання від буденності то що
відбувається це такий
магічний світ
А ти коли працюєш іноді забуваєш про
війну
в якийсь момент так
та вимикаєш реальність на мить А потім
знову повертаєшся
дівчачий клуб Дівчина можна назвати як
молоду жінку так і старшу пані і далі це
коли дівчина доглядає за собою завжди в
мирний час і під час війни обов'язково
особливо коли йду там на Донбас Я
слідкую за тим що Ну я виглядала
пристойно бо я їду все ж таки до хлопців
що ми не стали запускати себе що війна
війною а жінки залишаються жінками І
коли вони нас
приїжджає вони
бачать то їм хочеться все ж таки щоб ми
були Красиво а вони повинні
як ще нас побачити як жінки тобто мейк
руки зачіска
маленьке освідчення в любові до України
ще й на нігті готово
і ось вона зі своїми дівчатами знову в
дорозі з ними також і її майстриня з
манікюру Інна ми зараз спускаємося на
метро Хрещатик центральні станції
Київського метрополітену тут саме
найбезпечніше місце якщо не дай боже
будертування то станція знаходиться
настільки глибоко що люди всі вижили ми
вперше будемо на концерті ще й в метро
це дуже незвично А зараз відчуваємо всі
ці емоції які вони концерти в метро
Іра отримала квитки на цей концерт
посеред дня в метро
це прагнення до нормальності і водночас
станеться на вулкані постійне тепло і
холод Іра між манікюрним салоном
концертом і військовим фронтом
[музика]
[оплески]
як Ти справляєшся з цими різними світами
[музика]
і буду працювати вже на лінії фронті
десь через місяць Чому ти туди хочеш
дуже багато хлопців гине через те що не
знають як надати першу домедичну
допомогу на полі бою
Іра занурюється все далі у війну але її
нігті будуть виблискувати Також там Нам
це тепер Добре відомо
[музика]
уже через кілька років а саме У 2030
році в морі плаватиме більше частинок
пластику ніж риби припускають експерти
на суші ситуація ще більш драматична наш
світ потопає у пластикових відходах
молоді бельгійці працюють над
біорозкладними альтернативами Вони
вирощують гриби поки що Здебільшого для
ресторанів та органічних магазинів але
зараз вони показують що біологічний
пакувальний матеріал може рости навіть
із відходів гриби як універсальна річ
так би мовити
Брюссель У самому низу
підвалах тури таксі
це колишній великий торговий
перевантажувальний пункт стара
Промислова дільниця
[музика]
сьогодні в коридорах лабіринтах
процвітає зовсім інший бізнес а саме
живі організми
[музика]
на загальній площі у тисячу квадратних
метрів у місті вирощують їстівні гриби
чомусь усе це схоже на те що мимоволі
знаходиш у підвалі фільми жахів через
кілька тижнів гриби вилізуть із
поліетиленових пакетів
розведення чисте вільна від мікробів А
ще комах яких зазвичай приваблюють гриби
їх тут і близько немає
ми не перші хто вирощує гливи але ми
перші хто годує їх виключно органічними
відходами нашого міста
Наразі це в основному кавова гуща але
основна ідея пермафунгі полягає у тому
щоб найближчим часом переробляти всі
види органічних відходів з нашого міста
[музика]
це може вдатися оскільки як пояснює
Віктор гриби живляться різноманітною
їжею тому всі основні інгредієнти сіно
спори грибів каву вагуща у спеціальному
місці не просто змішується а й
пастеризується тобто очищаються
У них є захоплива альтернатива для
використаної культиваційної землі з
мішків її знову очищаються потім
змішують з іншими грибковими спорами
у збірних формах з цього виростають
теплоізоляційні плити
пакувальний матеріал навіть абажури для
ламп
єврокомісія визнала ідею достатньо
гарної щоб надати пермафонді 2 мільйони
євро це дозволить фірмі виробляти свої
прототипи для європейського ринку у
Великих кількостях
такий гриб росте у тисячу разів швидше
ніж деревом це є також неймовірною
перевагою
наше розведення потребує до Смішного
мало часу порівняно з промисловим
нафтохімічним або природним виробництвом
зараз пермафунді все що відома
високоякісними грибами особливо для
органічних крамниць
товар вручну зрізають щодня І взагалі
багато чого тут навмисне не
автоматизовано оскільки метою є
створення багатьох простих робочих місць
але коли на танці дає потім навантажений
велосипед Щоб відвести останні гриби в
крамниці він радіє що вибрався із
підвалу
[музика]
віскі що рятує віру це можливо коли
баварський католики здійснюють
паломництво до Шотландії залежить це не
лише від благородного напою а від
священника який перебуває Разом із ними
він інший і робить багато чого інакше і
популярність вольфганга роте Можливо
навіть переважає популярність деяких
його колег на вершині кафедри
виглядає Це дуже весело група баварських
паломників здійснює віскі паломництво до
Шотландії на чолі зі священником
[музика]
я церковний бунтар це священик який
потрібен громаді Якби його не було
довелося б його вигадати він людина віри
і він привносить у церкву рух
Алло чути мене зараз Чудово отже ми
готові до старту
Ласкаво просимо до обітованої землі
Шотландії
окрім огляду визначних пам'яток
Вольфганг проти та його група
подорожують від одного заводу дистиляції
до іншого для священика з Баварії віскі
це свята вода
найголовніше уважність
ми не просто п'ємо алкоголь ми
сприймаємо те що нам подають усіма
відчуттями
тож це не дикий запій а вправи на
уважність і водночас вправи на
помірність
паломники підходять до дегустації із
науковою серйозністю а деякі навіть не
куштують а лише нюхають це називається
коли ти дивишся так то дивишся прямо на
рай
Британські острови також є для
вольфгангарота дуже особливим і сумним
місцем сюди він подумки втікав коли йому
було дуже погано він розповідає Що у
2004 році єпископ намагався його
зґвалтувати
відсорому він роками мовчав але йому
ніхто не повірив навіть тоді коли він
нарешті порушив мовчання
[музика]
тим часом мені довелося визнати що у
моїй Церкві на жаль панує культура
мовчання
і приховуються речі про які необхідно
говорити
і виправити
але це тримають у таємниці
просто намагаються приховати
роди написав книгу про свою історію
обвинувачений єпископ подав на нього до
суду і програв удвох інстанціях
[музика]
Вольфганг проти порушує табу і так Йому
вдається повернути до церкви тих хто
сумнівається щодня в дорозі відбувається
молебень
ка
[музика]
пливе
Крістін залишила католицьку церкву понад
30 років тому хоча насправді Вона все ще
відчуває близькість до католицької віри
мене виховали в католицькому досі я все
ще відчуваю зв’язок із католицькою
церквою але вона для мене занадто
обмежена багато з того що вони говорять
позбавлене широких поглядів але я з
вольфганком бо знаю що він мислить ширше
під час свого особливого паломництва
Вольфганг гроте поєднує духовність і
віскі наступна зупинка завод дистиляції
бордерс
коли ви підійдете сюди вас вразить запах
але незалежно від цього Все буде добре
підніміться і понюхайте
[сміх]
перед заводом дистиляції чекає водій
автобуса Девід а він авозив уже багато
груп але особливо йому подобається група
що здійснює паломництво до віскі вони не
напиваються
І здається Їх цікавить як виготовляється
віскі та звідки воно походить
вони не пиячать і не блюють по всьому
автобусу
я чому дуже радий
під час паломництва довіски
вольфгангароте мова йде передусім про
більше ніж алкоголь він націлюється на
духовність і дух і Це здається працює
вже визначено дату наступного
паломництва
[музика]
ще один спосіб щоб знову залучити до
церкви більше людей Сподіваємось що ми
захоплюємо вас і безалкоголю дякуємо вам
за перегляди за вашу зацікавленість ми
повернемось до вас наступного тижня до
побачення
українською мовою озвучено центром медіа
ініціатив переклад Володимира та Олеся
Швед режисер Павло Тимченко текст читали
Олена потоцька Юрій Лисенко та Олесь
гоян Київ 2022 рік
[музика]